hey guys Greg knuckles here got some
footage from my training session last
night
like always I started with bench worked
up to 405 for a double it uh it felt
very much like a lifetime drug-free
bench session and by that I mean I felt
very weak could have been because I was
basically doing Crossfit between sets
just kidding
just getting my hips and everything
loosened up for what was to come which
was beltless low bar squats
these all felt pretty good actually
that was 545 felt very smooth just like
I wanted I really wanted to work up over
six today so I felt like I was set up
pretty well for that here on 585 you'll
see that I'm a little slower out of the
bottom than I'm used to just because I
haven't been squatting low bar too much
recently my adaptors aren't as strong as
as they once were but that's okay
they'll come back around pretty quickly
here's 615 and pretty much the same
thing it was it was never really in
question just just need to work on my
adductors to get a little more speed out
of the hole but this was actually the
heaviest I've ever squatted without a
belt so this this soon after coming back
from a six week layoff I'm pretty happy
with that so on the whole I'd say squats
felt maybe 15 to 20 percent natty well
that's all I've got guys so please like
and subscribe until next time thanks